so it's all too easy to forget about
certain parts of the world these days
it's all about na or EU or Korea or
China or Japan at least in the West we
tend to forget about the rest of the
world the Dominican Republic earned
their way to the top of the street
fighter world they overcame barriers
borders and gods to earn the rest of the
world respect but after their champion
won the biggest prize street fighter has
to offer he didn't spend it on himself
he spent it breaking down every obstacle
for his brothers and sisters back home
the Dominican Republic is a complicated
place it's a country fueled by tourism
and the opportunities for people who
live there are limited the average wage
is under $400 a month getting a visa to
the States can be complicated and for
most young people the dream of eSports
stardom seemed unattainable for the
longest time which meant that being the
best seemed like just a dream for a guy
like Menna Rd the VR scene was actually
just like any other scene there's a few
players that are dedicated to it but not
like you know got a lot of people
actually believing you can do it gaming
in the Dominican Republic was never
really gonna lead to anything resembling
a career but Minardi and his friends
stuck with fighting games my big brother
he plays fighting games and I grew up in
the same house as him he he was always
bidding me so I just started playing
fighting games because of him they hung
out in a sort of dojo at least that's
what they called it it was basically a
tiny room with a couple of setups
it wasn't exactly luxurious and you had
to be in the know to even show up for
locals even the power would sometimes go
out which isn't exactly ideal for
marathon training sessions
back in the we are like electricity goes
out at any random moment sometimes you
want to play but you can't because of
electricity and then there's the fact
that travel from the Dominican Republic
to the rest of the world often felt
impossible the earth citizens need a
visa to get to the US Canada and Europe
not to mention vast swaths of South
America where there are plenty of Capcom
Pro Tour events the dr scene regardless
of their actual skill were trapped the
Dominican Republic is just a great
example of how much scenes out there
just they're so good but you just don't
know it because they just don't have the
opportunity to travel so when Menna rd a
17 year old kid from the dominican
republic burst onto the scene in 2017 a
lot of people were surprised so I was
talking to my brother yikes a car and he
was like yell more mana Rd or is
definitely like top caliber yes is a
region-specific player that you have to
look out for a lot of people don't know
he is the manner Rd is definitely got
like oh that is gonna be that men are
arty with the many disrespect and he
moves on I mean we talked about this
manner Rd is a guy to beat he is one of
the creme de la creme over the course of
2017 men have built the reputation he
was bringing down solid players and in
premier tournaments he went from top 16
to top 12 to top eight patients and then
other sneeze oh my god are the Menace
skills got people talking but they also
caught him a spot in Capcom Cup capcom
cup isn't as well-known as say Evo it
doesn't have as many players it's not as
prestigious and for some people it's
just not as important but Capcom cub
does have the one thing that every
player wants the biggest prize in
fighting games every year the Capcom Cup
champion takes home a quarter of a
million dollars and firm NRD it could
make a huge difference going into Capcom
Cup though Menna Rd was just another one
of the 32 he didn't have an especially
high scene and his competition looked
fierce a former Evo champion round one
a former Capcom Cup champion round two
and in round three
the legendary Daigo Umehara was waiting
for him if he could make it past his
first two opponents but some people had
high hopes for the dominican upstart and
i remember when i looked at the top i
thought it was the favorite capcom Menem
brought down every single opponent in
his way
earning his spot in the top three and
guaranteeing himself a pretty nice chunk
of the prize pool but a lot of people
thought his run was basically over
because his next opponent with someone
no one good star very smart from
Chiquito
just doesn't want to deal with that
situation final match it was all the way
down that last-second meta could have
still taken it oh boy you see it on
Mena's face
Minna made it close but he couldn't
quite topple Tokita so he went down to
losers crushed nemo and earn another
shot at the Cape that time reacting to
the fireball getting the damage here
comes bet I wasn't enough oh boy a
cookie to all Gary man you jumped
and now oh limit switch sides to very
fortunate for judo gets them in the
corner is those scary men hearty no that
just need them away get away
Oh and men are G comes back and ties it
up wonder one with a great crunch come
back no here we go men rd with the
opportunity he's gonna get ahead but
he's gonna spend the critical eye right
away he wants to get Tokyo in a nervous
situation where the next hit could
potentially kill him anything
damage is it enough not quite you know
oh my god we're not oh boy another one
for the stun yes it's not gonna do it
quite yet but we are closer Toki don't
need something
it's not over but it's closer than it
was before
back and forth cookie dough just blocked
it out oh this almost so much damage
it's enough boy one hit and the critical
earth is in enough no birdie the big boy
stays alive
he's got the DX song for sure the
triggers they're amazing as you talk
though of all people miss that range a
little bit of pressure man throws maybe
a lot of pressure a couple boys Mehta is
on the verge of doing it so he don't
have to stay alive he can't get touched
if
[Applause]
after resetting the bracket Menna Rd
brought down Toki dough and one of the
biggest obsessed in fighting game
history a rookie player with barely a
year of tournament experience from a
country that no one had really ever
heard of and he beat one of the greatest
fighting game players of all time
but Minardi didn't really spend his
prize money on some of the sillier
things he could have bought he invested
his winnings right back into the
dominican republic fgc there was like a
dojo when we call it a club so that you
can play and I helped and put a lot of
money into it to make it better
we don't pay anymore over there we have
AC we have big screen to watch videos a
lot of setups but many of the real
efforts began with the Santo Domingo
Tigers first thing is I started on a
team and I started sending all the
players you know get the players to USA
and have them organized you know make
them grind a normal team then he built a
local Street Fighter circuit which sent
one champion to evo 2018 all expenses
paid and not only that but Menna rd and
all the other dominican players
continued success makes it a lot easier
for players from the Dominican Republic
to travel that we now have proof that
we're coming here to play and show to
the embassy or like yeah we travel here
whichever halo he's coming with us and
flight money we get support from
different companies I put a lot of money
into Marcin so all of them will travel
and have a place to practice it so it's
easier now it's not easy but easy and as
d our players started to travel more and
more they became known for their
boisterous support of their fellow
countrymen
while some people complain it was hard
to follow the dr players for just being
excited for one another well we have a
very strong national bright so it's in
all the sports the Dominicans are at
we're just like that we we love our
country we love being the best as a
country playing as a team Menna also
used the money to make game over the
dominican major it was a truly
international event that attracted
players from all over the world
something that was moving for many in
the fgc listen man the love is very like
I said before man I have advanced I was
11 so it's real emotional for me a lot
of people showing that love to me so
just to see all that love in that
embrace for people that actually support
me even though people that sometimes
don't even understand the language that
I'm speaking which is English back at
home they just know when they feel that
love men have built a better dojo one
where the ceilings didn't leak and the
power didn't randomly go out and his
success brought more people out to the
locals because help they wanted to try
to bring him down everybody we're
looking up to a new standard and then
when they were like yeah so this guy you
know well of us it's a world champ so we
can all be more champs them and they
started training a lot they were like
yeah we erased this kid you know because
I started when I was going over there
and they were like we saw and grew up
there's no way he's gonna be the only
one to do it
so we're gonna follow his steps he built
a foundation for players from the dr to
travel and dominate players all over the
world and in turn they did so we
punished not to fall through have to
count gonna convert uno
[Music]
the DRF GC wasn't just a scene that no
one was paying attention to it was a
scene that didn't really have much of a
shot at international success without
the infrastructure that mana our DS win
provided his decision to build up the
community that made him was selfless but
it also allowed them all to thrive now
we are a force to be reckoned with you
know you talk about good fighting it
players so you have to talk about the D
our mana our T's win a Capcom Cup
represented far more than just a win for
himself it was a win for an entire
country a nation full of talent worth
taking seriously his win through the
Dominican fgc into the spotlight this
generosity brought them to the world
he looked something to believe in in
life and this is what I believe in I
believe in my country and in my
community
you